you know uh when you say what is the
design philosophy of of developing an
airplane it's driven a lot by what the
customer wants when I had my own small
company where we had home build
airplanes most of the airplanes we
developed were never marketed so nervous
they weren't done for return on
investment they were done to explore
what might be cool there and they were
done for fun airplanes like the Grizzly
and average er of course and and and the
scaled is quite a bit different in that
it it it it has done several airplanes
that are developed with the funding from
our parent company the triumphs and the
Ares a light attack airplane were funded
by by Raytheon or Beechcraft which owned
us at the time but in general our work
is a customer that comes to us that has
a goal in mind for himself and he's
thinking about return on investment in
most cases and or if it's DARPA coming
to us they may be thinking of research
breakthrough we did we did one one DARPA
airplane that was really focused on on
looking for a breakthrough to do a
better airplane for the our desert one
failure here but at any rate most of it
most of them are RNAi including the the
commercial space thing now that's that's
being done in order for them to build a
business and and we have to meet real
specific goals because that's part of
their business plan so the environment
that we're put into has a lot to do with
a research
we'll take we are known for trying new
things even though we have a tough
schedule we did an airplane that we that
the customer wanted it flying within I
think is eight and a half months and we
elected on our own to try a totally new
manufacturing method for the wings and
tail surfaces and control surfaces
something that hadn't been done before
something that may not work something
that was really exciting and interesting
and if it did work its breakthrough
stuff and we decided to use it on a
program that had a real tough schedule
and you know at times you could question
the sanity of that but when people dig
in there and knowing that they have to
achieve that goal a lot of times you'll
find engineers in there at Friday nights
and Sundays and there in the shop
themselves building in and trying to
make it work and and and in general we
we do make it work
so a lot of it depends on what the
customer demands are
well um I encourage and it seems
backwards you think you get real
conservative as an old guy but I did
some of it just today typically I'll
look at the work done by the by the new
engineers and we've got a lot of them
who are just just a year or two or three
out of out of college and they tend to
do things that are sometimes complex
just because complexity looks cool and
it looks like a more significant design
result if something's complicated but
what I try to encourage people to do is
to have a breakthrough by finding a way
to do it more simply and even if the
real simple one has a chance of not
working because it's too simple we'll
try it anyway because in trying it
sometimes you'll stumble on to a
solution on why it wouldn't work and now
you've really add a big gain now you
have a simple thing that does work and
that's that's the real real challenge
now you can always make something work
by adding complexity but you can never
make something affordable by adding
complexity
aesthetics play a role when you have
finished an airplane get it ready to fly
and you paint it white usually our
composite airplanes have to be painted
white so their structure stays cooler
out in the Sun uh and then someone comes
along whose only job it is to do the art
work or the aesthetics and he puts the
trim colors on in the and the logos and
if you look at spaceship 2 for example
it has a wonderful portrayal of Richard
Branson's mother floating in space when
she was very young and as a model or
something in those days so the
aesthetics go on and paint on something
whose shape probably has nothing to do
with aesthetics a beautiful shape of an
airplane probably is one that has good
performance now that isn't true for
everyone's eyes if they look at
something real stubby that's supposed to
fly a long ways and has real short wings
to me that's ugly even though it looks
beautiful like a like a swept wing
spaceship or a fighter I know that for
something to have the range of Voyager
it has to have these real long slender
wings so frail that they bend way up so
to me when I look at that application I
see wonderful aesthetics in the shape of
a wing that I know will get the
performance goal and true also from the
stability and control and safety in the
short short field operations on so I I'm
I'm biased because I'm thinking of
performance and stability and control on
aesthetics but the answer your questions
if we take a wing tip and put that
beautiful sweep on it so it looks like a
shark fin that has nothing to do with
aesthetics that actually does give us
better induced drag and there was higher
performance
you